hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in part one of
the spoke zarathustra in the section
called of the new idol Nietzsche is
going to have his mouthpiece Zarathustra
set out a discussion that counterpoise
is what we can call the state to stop in
German against several other things one
of these is herds and people's Cukor and
the other is the solitary individual or
Association or a couple of solitary
individuals the kind of people that he's
writing this book for who would be the
ones trying to bring about something
greater than within and for Humanity
the state is in some respects a dead end
for Nietzsche although from the
perspective of the present and actually
going very far back into the past all
the way state to ancient Rome for
example or you could think of you know
all sorts of other states
similarly aligned like this there's a
kind of deception a kind of pretense
that's going on that the state really is
an advance forward nature sees it as not
an it not a decline but
actually sort of a cul-de-sac a dead-end
something that closes off greater
possibilities so he starts out by
contrasting the state against the people
or people's he says there are still
peoples and herds somewhere but not with
us not here in the presence we like to
talk about you know ethnic groups or
things like that but we're really all
within some sort of state and our
understanding of ethnicity or race or
whatever it may be is really kind of
false consciousness it's it's a
manufactured thing that in many respects
serves or at least is is oriented in
relation to the state and States so he
says here we have States we have nation
states we have administrative structures
they can often be quite complex you know
you can think of the Germany of
Nietzsche's own time which is a federal
republic you know a state of states
right or you can think of our own here
in the America our own complex system in
which there's you know a federal state
local all sorts of other things going on
every one of them would would qualify as
what nietzsche is calling a state so he
says well what is a state what is it he
says I'm gonna tell you about the death
of people now that's an interesting way
to begin isn't it the state comes about
through the death of people's the death
of a folk and he says that the first lie
is coming from the state and here's the
lie that comes out of its mouth I the
state and the people there's a tendency
and it can go both ways for people to
make two different sorts of errors one
is to actually do exactly what's being
said here take the state as its word I
the state and the people so you know we
identify for example the government or
the people who happen to be in charge at
any given time with the people that
they're supposed to be representing or
embodying in some way and that's a
mistake
because that's not the people we can
also go the other way when a group of
the people you know what's left of it
who generally misunderstand who they are
managed to gain control over the levers
of power of the state they come in and
they're like well now we're finally
going to have real Americans in charge
or real Germans or real whatever you
want and they're already deracinated
from you know whatever the people that
they came from actually was they just
have sort of pictures in their head
about that that they have an emotional
attachment to and then they get control
of the state and then they try to impose
that and that's just as false for
somebody like Nietzsche he says this
notion of the state is the people is a
lie why it was creators who created
people's and hung a faith and a love
over them and at that time they served
life we can't translate you know things
like ancient indo-europeans
into the present or even you know pick
whatever you like Vikings or you know
warrior groups of other sorts Normans
basically Vikings transmuted you can't
take that and put that into the present
as that somehow you know the guy sitting
in in the basement typing on the
keyboard is really a representative of
that even if he happens to do martial
arts or anything along those lines
Nietzsche would say that's nonsense so
he goes on and he says they served life
there was an orientation towards life
and then he said it is destroyers who
set snares for many and call it the
state they hang a sword in a hundred
desires over them then he notes that
where you actually still have a people
where there's still a Foulke they don't
understand the state and they hate it as
a matter of fact they view it as as he
says the sin against custom and law you
can
see this for example in the constitution
of the British state or the French state
you know it took lots and lots and lots
of convincing people to abandon their
old ways and eventually accept
absolutist state power and even then
sometimes they held on to those local
traditions and just kept them hidden he
says here's what's going on the state
produces a confusion about good and evil
itself why because every people speaks
its own language of good and evil its
neighbor does not understand this
language it invented this language for
itself in custom and laws so nature is
talking about a certain type of
relativity here of morality the basic
structure of good and evil is in place
in all these different people's right
but what exactly counts is good and evil
and why it counts as such is not
comprehensible is not you could say
exchangeable between them and then the
state comes in and the state brings all
these these peoples together and
operates on it and Nietzsche says the
state lies in all languages of good and
evil and whatever it says it lies and
whatever it has it is stolen everything
about it is false it bites with stolen
teeth even its belly is false and they
says confusion of the language of good
and evil this is the sign of the state
and he says this is as opposed to the
will to life and being life-affirming as
people's were this is actually death
affirming this is the will to death so
what is the state then it's kind of a
shadowy existence that somehow inserts
itself and gets everybody to buy into it
and it takes a lot of you know fighting
at first but eventually it becomes the
way in which we we understand things and
we're stuck within these states
now the second great feature of the
state as Nietzsche sets it out here is
that it exists or it was devised or
invented if one Minh didn't write
everyone didn't is the the past of that
it was devised for who not for the
people as a way to make the people work
better or something like that
that may have been on selling point it's
for the superfluous the people who don't
really matter that uber loosing it the
extra and you might say well that sounds
really bad well no no you have a growth
and then there's all these people in
place and they can't all be sort of
dominating the stage so the state comes
in and provides them with a way of life
that allows them to have and keep what
they you know produce or appropriate and
to have a sense of meaning and purpose
about their own essentially superfluous
lives so he says here we go many too
many are born the state was invented for
the superfluous see how it learns them
the many-to-many how it devours them and
chews them and reuse them so they're
they're in effect transformed by the
state they have their consciousness
formed and shaped by it and they accept
it they're like well yeah under the
state we live in all right I'll pay my
taxes I'll go and register my car at the
DMV I'll go to school like they tell me
to all you know follow the rules or when
I break the rules it'll be along the
lines that the state has you know more
or less allowed me to to break them and
I'll you know love with state loves and
hate with the state hates and and you
know reserved a little bit to myself but
that'll be what the state allows me to
keep and they live their entire lives
out within that structure now Nietzsche
has a few things to say about the many
to many in this case he says I call the
state where
everyone good and bad is a poison
drinker the state where everyone good
and bad loses himself the state where
Universal slow suicide is called
life so again another lie another
substitution Universal slow suicide is
as good as it's going to get so we call
that life and we we close our eyes to a
greater life possible for us and then he
says let's look at the works of these
superfluous people what gives them a
place and a purpose
he says they steal for themselves the
works of inventors and the treasures of
the wise they call their theft culture
now think about the present we have two
great ways on both the left and the
right that this happens we have cultural
appropriation happening on the Left
where people are you know saying oh
everything in the world belongs to us
and we're gonna celebrate all of it
we're not gonna really understand it too
well as a matter of fact the people who
are saying well you know these these
things coming from this group over here
they're a little bit more ambiguous than
than you'd like we're gonna put it on
t-shirts and and you know we're gonna
have websites for it and hats and we're
all gonna like March for it and and talk
about how great it is to be
multicultural nature would say well
that's there's the state for you and
that's superfluous people for you and
then you have them right and they're all
about you know tradition and Western
culture and you know you look at these
people and you're like wow I mean you
like Charlemagne if he was around today
he'd spit in your face and you know call
you a slave and you know say I don't
hate your help buddy and and vice-versa
for all these things all the people who
are celebrating the Romans or the Greeks
or the judeo-christian heritage or you
know the Vikings or you know this this
King in the Middle Ages or any of this
sort of nonsense about the Battle of
Lepanto right that's that's the same
sort of thing they're they're basically
from Nietzsche's perspective people
bragging about culture building and
they're living off of as essentially
value appropriators what people who
genuinely created value were able to do
he goes
Johnny says look at these superfluous
people they're always ill they vomit
their bile and call it a newspaper they
devour one another and cannot even
digest themselves the newspaper is a
great stand-in for any sort of news
media and we could also include the
entertainment media social media all of
these sorts of things Nietzsche would
say that's what you do to keep
superfluous people busy and you know
allow them to have their little say and
then they feel ok with themselves
because nominee talks about wealth
generation he says they acquire wealth
and make themselves poor with it they
desire power and especially the love the
lever of power plenty of money these
impotent people think about how many
people brag about how rich they are
spend money on status symbols even the
ones who like you know are saving at
first and bragging about how thrifty
they are look at their lives see whether
they are truly filled with the you know
great value that wealth can bring and
the power and prestige and all the
celebrity that comes with it see if
they're actually fulfilled or if they're
constantly comparing themselves against
others always on the make always having
to tell more and more lies that they you
know somehow convince themselves aren't
lies through some ideology or another
all of those things are what the state
allows it creates a playground for what
Nietzsche is calling the superfluous
Nietzsche would probably be ok with that
but the biggest problem with the state
is that it takes the people who are
higher than that who wants something
more who feel alienated and yet want to
express their energy who are
life-affirming and it makes a devil's
bargain with them it Corral's them in
and lers them into serving the state so
he says it whispers its dismal lies to
you to great Souls it Divine's the
abundant hearts that like to squander
themselves you you you know grew weary
and battle now your weariness sir is the
new Idol it would like to range heroes
and honorable men about at the new Idol
it likes the Sun itself in the sunshine
of good conscience --is it will give you
everything if you worship it this new
Idol thus it buys for itself the luster
of your virtues and the glance of your
proud eyes why because it uses this to
lure in the many to many so the better
people the ones who are active dynamic
who would in some respects break out of
this ideological system get brought back
into it to be its props its tools it
slurs for the superfluous who you can
expect to not do any better than that so
who are these these are the artists
these are the the dynamic politicians
the Warriors these are the great
thinkers the people who look at things
and say this can't be all that there is
they get sucked in as well now Nietzsche
says that there is a possibility of
getting out of this he says that we need
to find a different path he says do you
want to suffocate in this better to
break the window and leap into the open
air now that means putting behind
oneself all the safeguards and
guarantees that the state would bring he
says the earth still remains free for
great Souls many places are still empty
for solitaries people who go off by
themselves and for solitary couples
people who could be friendships it could
be a romantic relationship it could be
you know master and and you know student
or something like that and he says a
free life still remains for great Souls
only there where the state ceases does
the man who is not superfluous begin
everybody is superfluous within the
state even the great becomes superfluous
so he says there does the song of the
necessary man the unique and
irreplaceable melody begin and that is
where the state ceases and he says do
you not see it the rainbow
bridges to the Superman so in order for
people to actually accomplish what it is
that Nietzsche is laying out as a
possibility in this work they would have
to find some way of evading the state
now Nietzsche poses it as like going off
to some wasteland but perhaps it could
be done within the belly of the beast
perhaps it could be done within the
midst of the state but one would have to
reject all of this and perhaps I suppose
live a sort of double life
you